思わなかったけど
千葉先生とか千葉見に教えてください
教えていただきました
いいよ
よく読ませていただきました
あ、そうか
まあ懐かしい
今も場で来いながらそんなに簡単に入れないし
でも、試合があれば解決して
千葉公園はちょっと行ってますけど
大学の試合があると
見に来ても
ちょうどその時千葉先生がやっちゃった
あと、おたるさんとか
おたるさんとか
なんか、おだるさんと言われて
本当に私たちとりゃ
できる
なんか、お花させなさいな
そうですね
それをやったし
ちょっとやるいま
大丈夫
いっ
誰か
たぶん
秋子さん
うん、秋子さん
たち
何まで書いていただきましたか
ぜひやる
また、ご案内します
ありがとうございます
東京の方に使う
今、東京なんですけど
その、家庁なんかやってた娘が今アメリカにする
ああ、おもちゃのほう
そう、おもちゃのほう
そう
あの、子供の3人はこれが仕組みなんだけど
3人いてやりたければやる
いいなって言って
じゃあ、おたるさんのおはような気持ちのほうが書いて
はい、はい。
インスタグラム。
どうぞ、やっててください。
ありがとうございます。インスタグラムある。
やってます。これも僕のタックスにしてます。
ありがとうございます。
馬は乗られないんですか?
いやー、すっごい昔子供の頃乗ったことあるんですけど。
でも、馬の家系ですから、皆さん。
全然。
いやー。
馬はね、見ると、あ、乗る。
でも、乗るより、一緒に生活する。